the DNA of people who are waking up and
finding each other we're typically a
community of people that lift each other
up how you doing you guys got this going
awesome how can I support let's
collaborate let's do this let's do that
we're doers we'll go make the money
we're doing our part but you know for
the mo longest time the saying is what
never talk politics never talk religion
never talk this and that's been fed over
and over and over again you never do
that with your YouTube channel or
podcast trust me you're going to lose
half the audience
but no I think I think the reason why I
have a lot of Hope for the future of
America is because the right people are
finding each other and they're they're
United and they're setting aside
Ambitions and they're saying n man
listen you're for Freedom I'm For
Freedom let's roll let's go good good
let's roll that's what's happening
Freedom Fighters fting each other